in the uk boris johnson is generating
controversy even after agreeing to step
down as prime minister some are calling
for him to leave office immediately
instead of waiting for a successor to be
picked that race is already well
underway with many possible contenders
in the conservative party charlie
dagetta is following this outside the
prime minister's official residence
charlie good morning
good morning to you dana yes you could
call it the long goodbye like maybe
months long and as you said there are
many that are saying that the prime
minister should leave immediately
meanwhile the race for his replacement
is underway
thank you
boris johnson has not left the building
his exit has been just as messy as the
end days deciding to hang on and hold
out until a new conservative party
leader has been found has caused chaos
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
but as the sun set on the day he stepped
down that decision has driven a wedge
between his party and the public alike i
don't know why we're shocked really it's
boys it's going to be like it it's going
to be a big old tear up with you know
all of them trying to get leader become
leaders so i think they i think he
should stay for the time being until
they sort themselves out are you going
to make a bid for the leadership sir
sorting themselves out could take months
around a dozen potential contenders will
be fighting for the crown campaigning
and betting is already underway
british media has even speculated that
one reason he won't let go is a belated
big wedding bash at the end of the month
with wife kerry planned at checkers the
country estate that comes with the top
job if you have a prime minister who
says no
i'm not going to go i'm staying exactly
where i am we're in unprecedented
territory here we don't know because our
politics relies on the fact that the
prime minister will broadly speaking
play by the rules
and today boris johnson is not playing
by any rule
now we may learn more about that rule
book when johnson shares his plans next
week many say he should just hand over
to the deputy prime minister meanwhile
he's not going anywhere nate
charlie and london thank you